how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it seems like the future of the MCU is
coming together quite nicely we've had
the entire phase 4 slate revealed and
many reports on what to expect from
phase 5 not to mention that it seems
like the big bads of the MCU have
seemingly been revealed through many
different leaks and reports and those
are claimed to be Doctor Doom and
Galactus reports say that the MCU is
going to be split into two different
categories that are going to be the
cosmic heroes and the cosmic villains
which will be Galactus and then they are
going to be the earthbound heroes and
the earthbound villains which of course
is going to be Doctor Doom and recently
it's been reported by Charles Murphy
that Doctor Doom is going to be the main
villain of Black Panther - he'll be
invading Wakanda in search for that
precious metal vibranium but it seems
like that may not be the only phase 5
movie that Doctor Doom is going to be
the villain in according to a recent
leak on 4chan and reddit Doctor Doom is
also going to be the villain of Ant Man
3 and if we break down what happened in
ant-man and the wasp and if we break
down why Doctor Doom would want
vibranium from Wakanda this actually
makes a lot of sense
quick reminder to subscribed with
notifications turned on like the video
and comment below so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 so during the Infinity Saga
Thanos would randomly pop up in the MCU
we saw him in the post-credits scene of
the first Avengers film and the second
Avengers film age of Ultron and we even
saw him in person in guardians of the
galaxy eventually he went on of course
to become the biggest villain that the
MCU has ever seen and got two movies
basically devoted to his story but it
seems like Marvel has different plans
for building up their villains in the
future phases to come as I mentioned
it's been reported that Doctor Doom is
going to be the main villain of the MCU
on earth it's also been reported that
he's going to be the main villain of
black panther 2 and it's been reported
that he's going to be a villain in
ant-man 3 that's a lot of airtime for a
future big bad but what's going to
happen is that it seems like we're going
to see Doctor Doom rise to power
Thanos without the Infinity stones was
already one of the strongest beings in
the universe we didn't need to see him
rise to power he was already powerful
and he already had an army dr. doom
however does
really have an army and isn't an
all-powerful being yet however if both
of these leaks end up being true it
seems like dr. doom is building
something
if the leaks end up being true then dr.
doom is going to Akhanda to get the
strongest metal on earth vibranium and
then if the ant-man three leak ends up
being true that means that dr. doom or
Victor Von Doom is the mysterious
benefactor from ant-man and the wasp an
ant-man and the wasp sunny birch worked
for a mysterious benefactor who wanted
Hank Pym slab according to this leak
Victor Von Doom is the benefactor
now why would Victor Von Doom want Hank
Pym slab well you can tie this back to
the comics actually what is known in the
MCU as the quantum realm debuted in the
1963 s Fantastic Four number 16 in a
story called the microworld of Doctor
Doom in this issue Doctor Doom makes his
return after apparently being shrunk
into non-existence six months earlier
instead it was revealed that while he
was in the quantum realm he conquered a
peaceful primitive and happy world so as
you can see here Doctor Doom has
connections to the quantum realm and
what could be happening is that the
Fantastic Four could be hiding in the
quantum city that we saw in ant-man and
the wasp and Doctor Doom wants Hank Pym
technology so he can go and defeat them
finally or another thing that could be
likely to happen is that Doctor Doom
needs Hank Pym technology so he can go
inside of the quantum realm to use it to
conquer the earth he could use Hank Pym
technology to shrink down to a size
where nobody could see him coming this
essentially would make it so nobody
could defend his attack and if he is
planning an attack on the world then
he'll probably need some weapons and
some armor and what better to make
weapons and armor out of than the
strongest material known to earth
vibranium so again if these leaks end up
being true and Doctor Doom is going to
be one of the big bats of the MCU it
does seem like he's planning something
major here getting Hank Pym x'
technology in ant-man and the wasp and
possibly ant-man 3 and then invading
Wakanda to get vibranium it seems like
Earth may be in trouble but let me know
what you think what do you think Doctor
Doom is planning by invading Wakanda to
get some vibranium and by trying to get
Hank Pym slab let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and also
don't forget to subscribe with
notifications turned on
and like the video so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
also don't forget to click the link
below for your chance to win an Infinity
Gauntlet and don't forget to use code
cosmic @ G fuel comm for 30% off your G
field as always thank you all so much
for watching we'll forth